[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais non
est ce que ce n'est pas plutôt vous qui
essayait d'attirer son attention de
meghan markle départ alors je vais vous
dire je vous le dis franchement meghan
markle pas du tout je sais ce que je
sais où elle en est ses sketches hier je
suis pour faire à l'heure anglaise c'est
moi au f word et moi j'en ai de susciter
parce qu'elle m'a envoyé une photo elle
sur mon portable rien surmontées même en
voyant une photo à la main via mon
entraîneur m'a envoyé une photo du bébé
beaucoup plus proche
regardez regardez si la ressemblance
n'est pas évident
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais bon je te manque jean-michel été
complètement saisi par votre imitation
de patrick bruel
ouais mais j'ai remarqué qu'ils avaient
vu un nouvel hymne national art ou
l'arrêter c'est la bonne avant je croûte
j'ai presque oui la broque on me dira je
veux rire dans le game
[Musique]
regardez le film
[Applaudissements]
pas si bête
tout
c'est quoi
problème gilles courteau
et comme les bonnes graisses moi de
chanter
et m
[Musique]
ouah ça puisse aussi je veux le temps
je vais vous demander pardon surtout
pour un truc c'est pour le chocolat
m
g
c
je
[Musique]